waiting patiently preparing to set out
her vision for scotland
but within weeks could she be shaping
the next government of the united
kingdom
here in glasgow revealing a manifesto
for an election
she made happen making a promise that
she would stop at nothing to keep
conservatives
out of power a prime minister in boris
johnson
who is dangerous and unfit for office
apart from a push for another scottish
independence referendum
lots of snp promises similar to those in
labour's manifesto
a vote for the snp in this election is a
vote
to reverse austerity and to protect
our nhs a vote for the smp
is ultimately a vote for someone who
will put jeremy corbyn in power
in a hung parliament where no one has a
majority
first minister do you think that jeremy
corbyn is
personally anti-semitic and if that is
the
question a question in this general
election how can you even
think of being able to put him in number
10 if you get the chance
i don't know jeremy corbyn personally
well enough to answer
that question but i do say unequivocally
emphatically
that he has failed to get to grips with
this
problem and this issue within his party
but if jeremy corbyn's in a position
and labourer in a position of being able
to form a minority government
then better to have the influence of the
snp in there
the 59 scottish seats she is fighting to
win are disproportionately important
on election night scotland matters
one in three of the most marginal seats
in the uk is here in scotland
the 13 tory mps elected in 2017
meant that theresa may stayed in downing
street
nicola sturgeons made clear that she
would put jeremy corbyn in power
if she gets the chance defending jeremy
corbyn
this week of all weeks isn't easy the
bottom line in this election
is that a vote for nicolas sturgeon's
snp is a vote to put jeremy corbyn in
downing street i would much rather
scotland wasn't in a position of having
to choose between
the devil and the deep blue sea when it
comes to westminster parties or leaders
but
you know we have to deal with the
reality you are prepared to put a leader
who by your own admission doesn't deal
properly with the anti-semitism question
um seems to be a price worth paying what
just that sentence i wish jeremy corbyn
wasn't leader of the labour party i but
you know the alternative that is boris
johnson who
has got his own charge sheet on you know
racist comments and
attitudes nicola sturgeon won't even
attempt to do deals over who is pm in a
hung parliament even as she sets down
policy red lines labor says it isn't
having any of it
there'll be no back room deals no front
room deals
no coalitions no deals of any
description
with the snp the liberal democrats or
anyone else
we want to get a majority labour
government i believe we will
nicola sturgeon triggered this election
to make gains
they may come but the signs in scotland
are the tory voters holding up possibly
leading to a majority boris johnson
government
is this what the first minister really
wanted
sam coates sky news glasgow